[Music]
so the talk is called research workloads
I'm preemptable VMs I'm Michel Basilian
product manager Google I'm joined by two
friends from two sigma
kristin retriever they'll give a little
bit of more of an introduction in the
second half when they talked about their
workloads on preemptable VMS so here's
the outline i'm going to talk for a few
minutes about what panto VMS are and how
they work and what the general concept
is and then the two sigma guys will tell
their story cool all right so if I have
to tell you what a preemptable VM is in
one slide and if there's one thing that
you remember from my half of the talk is
that a pre-emptive IAM is a regular vm
like any other vm that you can get on
compute engine there's just two caveats
one is that it cannot run for more than
24 hours we limit the lifetime in the
uptime of the game for 24 hours and the
other is that we reserve the right to
take them away with 30 seconds of notice
at any point right that's right there in
the name that's what makes the
preemptable the upside of it is that
they only cost one cent per core hour
and that includes Intel skylake s--
that's up to 80% cheaper than a regular
GCE VM if you attach a GPU to the m2
that preemptable vm it'll be about 70
percent cheaper than a regular GPU if
you attach the local SSD to that
preemptable vm it'll be around 40%
cheaper then it's then a local SSD
attached to a standard vm and local this
is the you might have heard already at
some point today or in one of the other
talks is our high performance attached
storage for virtual machines the other
highlight is that prices are constant
there's no bidding of any kind this is
the price that what you see is what you
get in terms of price that doesn't
change cool so what good what can you do
with computers just sort of randomly
disappearing with 30 seconds of notice
there's actually quite a few things that
we've seen people do really anything
that's embarassingly parallel or
pleasantly parallel some people say
anything that is high throughput or is
it composed of a lot of independent
tasks that can be solved independently
we're losing a single machine doesn't
mean that everything
disappears or if you can figure out how
to capture state for your computations
so Monte Carlo simulations where
different machines are solving different
input conditions image understanding
rendering media transcoding anything
really to do with images if you imagine
a use case where you have 1000 images
and you want to assign each of those to
one of 100 printable VMs to do some
processing on that image if that VM goes
away because it gets preempted
you don't really lose anything except
for that image and you can be scheduled
at work if your scheduler knows how to
handle that
and I'll talk about that in a little bit
data analysis of course our data proc
product supports preemptable VMs
genomics and health life and health
workloads if you search the web for
Broad Institute printable VMs you'll see
a lot write-up of their use case
financial analysis of course and you'll
hear more about that in the second half
and many many others including physics
math chemistry and so on and to be clear
people are using these to solve very
real workloads so on any given day we
have 10 to 50,000 core clusters of
preemptable VMs being used multiple ones
and the largest we've ever seen is MIT
math professor doing some research in a
weekend on 580,000 course so this was
around two to three hundred four years
of compute in a weekend okay using them
is relatively straightforward and easy
there's just one flag that you have to
do like I said they are like regular
regular GC VMs you can figure them like
a regular GC VM or you do that a - -
preemptable - your command line or in
the UI you just select print ability on
or in the API select print ability to be
true generally of course you're gonna be
creating more than one of these things
and so that's where things get a little
bit more interesting but fortunately
there's a lot of tools that make it easy
we have our GCE managed instance groups
that can help you manage instances of
orientable VMs and recreate them once
they get preempted
we have a published solution on our
website for how to use HD Condor which
is a very popular job scheduling tool
with preemptable VMs kubernetes and gke
of course support preemptable VMs and in
the second half you'll hear more about
two Sigma's Cooke job scheduler that
supports scramble games as well so I
wanted to give you guys some best
practices for how to use preemptive VMs
to make the most of them and to minimize
the preemptions
so like old-school telephone companies
nights and weekends are best obviously
one avoid times when the data centers
are busy you want to architect your
system for regular preemption you should
expect their preemptions will happen
they're not a one-off rare situation we
see on historical rates 5 to 15 percent
preemption rates you should know that
this will change as a function of your
the VMs that you build the zones you use
in time of day and of course you should
be prepared to move regions and zones if
we are curious get really high in a
place but that's good cloud practice
anyway beyond that use shutdown scripts
and checkpoints to a safe State if
that's appropriate for your workload I'm
talking about standard GCE shutdown
scripts that are just part of Linux
the smaller the less choosy the VM the
less likely it is to be preempted so a
64 core preemptable VM with localist is
the N GPU is much more likely to be in
somebody's way than a 16 core
preemptable VM on the website we also
have a bunch of best practices that
outline a lot of this with a lot more
detail and you can read cool and I'm
gonna turn over to the two sigma team
good morning everyone I'm Chris Portier
with two sigma so I'll talk about a bit
about our research were closed on
protocol VMs so quick disclaimer even
though we're a technology conference
most of us are technologists we work in
a financial firm so we are not here to
talk about selling exultation of
securities or instruments we're not
giving you any stock advice etc etc etc
I really just talked about our
technology story so who are we
so I'm Chris I was four
we had a private cloud engineering of to
Sigma currently the head of public cloud
engineering a lot of that work really is
figuring out how do we adopt cloud
computing and bring it into our company
especially the native services which are
really interesting for us and a few
minutes we hear from Rodrigo also works
on my team he spends a lot of our time
figuring out our distribute computer
environment using GCP a lot of it is on
preamp old virtual machines so on our
section of the agenda we're going to
talk a little bit about batch research
and what that means to us and how we do
it a little history of a distributed
compute environment and give you a taste
of what it looks like today a bit about
how we build platforms on GCP and then
some of the challenges and takeaways
which is kind of the interesting things
for most people so battery batch
research process how does two Sigma's a
quant hedge fund and so how does a quant
hedge fund make money and survive in the
world you may envision there's a model
or that comes up with this idea Oh
Eureka here's how we're gonna make money
draws on a technique on a whiteboard and
poof it becomes a production that's how
it works in the movies right so not
exactly we the modeling workflow
actually looks fairly similar to like
it's a typical developer workflow
there's an idea of what they want to do
they do some work with it they do some
data analysis and shifting of data to
figure out what makes sense and they try
to write some techniques out and then
they want to simulate it usually
research back testing in the market like
hey how would this have performed over
the past in number of years and then
from there once they actually figure out
hey this is gonna actually work for us
they do a typical a review process so
similar to a code review they write
papers up they present it to their peers
they figure it out and it becomes a
production product at some point a lot
of what we use Google Cloud for is that
technique and data and the simulation
area a lot of the data analysis tools a
lot of the simulation back-testing we're
running on Google today and especially
the simulation of Korean pull of VMs is
where GCE really shines for us so a bit
about our distributor compute
environment and kind of over the history
over the past 15 or 16 years as legend
has it when two Sigma's founded a couple
of found there's a couple of early
employees time shared compute based on a
white board literally just on the white
board hey you know Bob has it this week
you know Suzy has it next week
cetera and I guess it worked for a few
years but it was three years or so what
I'm told early 2004 the team decided to
work on an internal scheduling system
really just uh yeah we want to be
technologists we want to figure out a
better system than a whiteboard quite
frankly so that worked well for
apparently eight years or so the
internal one and rum 2012 maces came on
the scene and really captured our
attention it sold a lot of the really
interesting like lower-level problems
how do you do
resource management how do you do
scheduling those are the types of things
like you know how do you execute a job
on this host isn't something that is a
core competency of what to segment
wanted to be or wants to be so we really
adopted maces full speed with that but
we still want to maintain as fair share
of scheduling things so even back in the
early days of white board okay we want
efficient utilization we want to share
it across everyone so we decided write
what is now known as to cook framework
which is a framework for fair share
scheduling of jobs on maces and we've
been using that ever since 2012 when I
first started writing it so 2016 cloud
computing two years ago was definitely a
mainstream concept we decided we really
wanted to start working with that and
figuring out how do we use elastic
capacity up to that at that point we'd
always had physical data centers you
know everything is here's the hardware
here's what we can use so we started
making a lot of changes to it connect
our data centers to the cloud and then
changes to cook and Mesa AZ to work in
these environments and then now mid 2018
we have real dynamic cloud compute which
has really been very beneficial for us
to be able to say what is our workload
what can we do we're not limiting our
modelers based on the compute that we
can get to them anymore but there's a
caveat though now we're gonna talk about
a minute about even though we have
elastic dynamic compute we don't have
dynamic storage or networking or other
things though we have a talk about a few
minutes about how we're still running
hybrid cloud with Google and our third
data centers there we go so a little bit
of capacity over time which kind of just
symbolizing what I just mentioned where
over time is a very step function you
know on this date we decided to order a
whole bunch of servers and put in a data
center and that's how it lasted for I
don't know 15 years or so and mid 2016
you start to see a lot of done
Spike's based on user workload this is
really when cloud computing became a
thing for us so one it opened up compute
ability for our modelers but also proved
the theory that we had years before is
that our demand isn't linear it's not a
oh here's what we're gonna use today
it's a lot more opportunistic based on
what's phase of research somebody is in
and then so that's a bit of the history
that's how we about how we got today but
what are our users so if we think about
Rodrigo and I are we working with called
platform engineering so we deal with a
lot of the lower level how do you build
a system how do you get resources
available to somebody and there are
teams above us so we think of modeling
engineering which the next step above us
that use our platform as a building
block modeling engineering does a lot of
stuff to work with techniques with data
analysis a lot of like how to run a
simulation then above them we have
quantitative engineers quantitative
engineers they work a lot closer to the
modelers and they work with actually
writing the models actually running
techniques writing tactics writing these
the actual code that will eventually do
trading and then finally we have
modelers who are our researchers that
are going through trying to find
information that is tradable and
actually usable so we have a bit of a
description of kind of the workloads and
this is where fair share of scheduling
actually comes back to us and it's kind
of important is that even though we have
all the dynamic compute I mentioned we
don't have dynamic storage we don't have
dynamic networking yet so we still wanna
be able to fair share our resources with
people and we also still care about
things like quotas we still care what
the bill looks like every month we care
about a lot of those types of things so
we think of the workloads that we're
running again modeling engineers who are
building just right above us like
they're doing scheduling cook schedulers
are doing other things they need a
little bit of capacity you know a few
hundred gigabytes a few a few tens 20s a
V CPUs to test out their work the folks
doin quantitated the quantitative
engineers though because their work is
closer to models actually wanna test
like hey does this model actually work
like from a technical standpoint they
need more they need to do more testing
and then our modelers they're probably
an infinite number of data sources and
things to trade on in the world and our
modelers want to run every single one of
those
which of course is impossible so they
are the highest demand of usage across
my company which actually these slides
all are showing that kind of this what
we see from our internal usage patterns
yeah and I that note I'll turn it over
to Rodrigo to talk about how we actually
build platforms in GCP thank you Chris
so you know Chris just talked about how
we kind of help how the environment has
evolved over time and also capacity how
used to be these like very nice a step
function and in recent years is more
like bursting and also how kind of how
we view our users how they share this
platform and you know we can think about
all of this as like very cool data and
we can do some more analysis and dig
into it or we can take that as
requirements which is what I think we've
been you know doing for the last two
years right so when you think about this
environment we really have like two
requirements one you know following the
assumption that the man is very bursty
we need to be able to scale up and down
you know automatically and and you know
to we you know like everyone is sharing
this platform but everyone has different
needs so we we're not in a position
where we kind of impose people what
resources they get we want you know this
cluster to be driven by the man right
and as we started to to move these were
close to the cloud we kind of came up
with two guiding principles right the
first thing that I want to talk about is
security right we take security very
seriously two sigma as you can imagine
this environment is one of the most
sensitive one because you know it has
some you know good stuff going in there
so we stick to GCE and some core
networking products like interconnects
to provide connectivity back and forth
it into Sigma and GCP I'm not going to
talk more about security in this
presentation because other guys you know
Nick and Michael from-from to Sigma or
are giving you know enough thoughts on
the topic the next thing that I want to
talk about though is kind of the other
thing that we always try very hard to
keep in mind which is you know LST City
add value to the users add value to the
business and do so in a cost-effective
way
because we've been operating data
centers for you know 10 15 years we know
how much it costs to run these
environments right and we cannot just
you know go to the cloud and start like
spending money like crazy because this
shiny new thing or like because everyone
is doing it we have to be able to add
real value and we need to be able to do
that in a cost-effective way
right now premium tool VMs and custom
machine types is what real allows us to
do that we get the 80% you know flat
discount and then with custom machine
types we create exactly the resources
that cook needs I'm gonna talk more
about cook but that cook needs to
schedule these jobs now this is a fairly
large environment and I don't want to be
on the hook you know creating and
deleting VMs all the time and creates
I'm sure does someone need to be on the
hook for to do that so we need an
autoscaler which is a product that you
know we've been working on since early
2016 so now if you take the autoscaler
you you know you take prem to OPM's and
you take custom machine types now you
get all the kind of building blocks to
build this platform where you can you
know scale to you know a couple of two
signal data center sizes for let's say a
a single user right before you know
before 2016 they had to share all this
platform between you know each other now
it's just a matter of like putting stuff
in some queue and then you're gonna get
capacity eventually but before talking
about auto scaling I want to talk about
cook a little bit because cook sits at
the top of the stack and without cook
there really isn't much right what are
these beings good for if nothing is
running on them so cookies and message
framework early versions were developed
back in 2012 it's open source and it has
this like very core concept of fair
scheduling that that we've used for that
we use both both on Prem and in the
cloud but just for different reasons
first scheduling essentially just
guarantees that no one user you know
takes over an entire cluster which is
super important when you're running on
Prem but let me give you an example I
think it's gonna be kind of a lot easier
to understand it's just me talking about
it so suppose a user read here has been
running overnight a bunch of jobs right
and he got lucky here at the entire
cluster but it's 780
New York time and now you know we have
like three in modelers that want to run
jobs you know there's one kind of
obvious problem here there's no capacity
to run all this additional jobs but
there's another problem right let's say
we make up some capacity somehow now we
need a way to determine who goes first
you know we can do some kind of
round-robin we can do a first-come
first-serve we can do random or we can
do kind of fair sharing which is what
Cooke does so essentially it's going to
take this virtual queue so you know each
one of these three virtual queues it's
gonna merge them into one global queue
and then it's gonna gonna order them by
furnace and furnace fear means you know
it's gonna take it's going to look at
what's your current usage
what's your backlog and then based on
that it's gonna determine some kind of
ordering then on the background it's
going to preempt some of red jobs and
then it's gonna schedule everything else
there is a downside to this kind of
situation which is you know red is we
lost some computation time that we've
already done but it's not a big deal and
I think it's much much about much better
than just making people wait eventually
those jobs are gonna get back you know
are gonna get put back in the queue now
you might be thinking like you're we're
at a cloud conference why don't you just
create more VMS and you know be done
with it you need to preempt anyone which
is you know kind of fair and you know it
kind of works in theory we're less
constrained with capacity we have access
to more machine types but now by having
this elastic cluster we created the
problem for ourselves right now we we
have this ramp up latency so suppose
there's like I don't know 10,000 jobs in
the queue and somehow we magically
decide that we need a thousand teams if
I send you know a thousand requests to
GCP well first of all there's like API
droid Libertines right so I cannot just
fire a thousand requests all at the same
time and then there is no guarantee that
I'm gonna get a thousand VMs like right
now and even if I could get them right
now remember we we work in a very secure
environment these VMs need to get an
identity they need to register to other
security services they need to register
to mesos and then cook eventually needs
to schedule these jobs so all of these
kind of steps they take time you know
couple minutes here a couple of minutes
there and then when you add up
everything it's time that is
non-negligible and the user can actually
feel it so we want to avoid that and you
know cook and share sharing is what
allows us it's kind of the thing that we
use to solve this problem it allows us
to share resources as they come up and
as they become available so now that we
talked about cook we can start talking
about auto-scaling
because you know cooking the autoscaler
work together and it's kind of the next
logical step in this tank so I think I
mentioned this before the first version
we wrote it in 2016
kind of one of the reasons why we wrote
the autoscaler
is because we wanted to have a deep
integration with the rest of the two
sigma ecosystem in particular cooking
mazes and then we also wanted to take
the opportunity to you know give cook
the right resources by creating the
right machine types over time as we
iterated on on launch e we've started to
use more and more and more custom
machine types and now we're at a point
where we almost exclusively use custom
machine types and then the other thing
is like as the usage of the cloud grew
as you know we started to move more and
more workloads into the cloud we had to
expand to multiple regions and we had to
expand to multiple zones to try to avoid
preemption and we had to write some you
know code here and there into launching
to be able to kind of chase this
capacity right because you could be you
can have a pretty large cluster in one
zone and then you could do some
percentage but you still have the job so
you need to run those jobs somewhere and
launch it allows us you know launch and
cook together they allow us to do these
type of things you know high-level
overview of launch is a essentially big
loop first thing that we're gonna do is
check for idle or any healthy VMs this
is essentially scaling down you know if
the VMS are idle just a scaled down then
we're going to look at the job queue in
cook if there's something we keep it in
memory otherwise we just you know stop
scaling then we check for what we call
limits limits here could be GCP quotas
could be internal limits like you know
don't spend more than X amount of money
per hour
Don's been you know don't create more
than X number of VMs on a given time
window
because remember they have to talk to
internal services these services are
kind of developed for or are kind of set
up for some maximum peak load so we
cannot just like I start hammering them
if all the checks are good if all the
checks and balances are good then we
compute what we call the runnable subset
of jobs that essentially is you know
look at the job queue let's say I'm a
user and I have a quote of a thousand
jobs and I already have 500 jobs running
if I put two thousand more jobs on the
queue obviously only five hundred are
gonna get scheduled so we don't want to
create resources for two thousand jobs
we only want to create resources for 500
jobs so that's what the runnable subset
means now that we have the requirements
we can actually go and you know compute
the machine types that we're going to
use the input of this function is
essentially just the list of
requirements and the output is almost a
fully well-formed payload that we can
send a rule so it's something like you
know create 200 VMs of type X and you
know another 150 of type Y and something
like that and then the last thing you
know to kind of wrap it up we need to
know where to put this VM so the last
step in the scaling loop is figuring out
where to create these VMs you know we
have the payloads already and we send a
request to Google hopefully we get
everything that we want it and then we
write some more metrics to do further
analysis of line or you know we're gonna
use these metrics also on the
distribution calculation in the next
loops so if you put coke and launch it
together this is kind of pretty much
what you did this is an intraday graph
of you know capacity in to Sigma till
you have the used resources and I don't
know if you can see it here but like
there's a little spike in green which is
provisioned resources so there's usually
like a little discrepancy between what
we create and what's actually being used
which is not a big deal I think you know
we were okay leaving with that but I
think the most the more interesting
things here is kind of the fact that
this graph well clearly is very spiky
right and the spikes are very
short-lived so this data
our initial assumption that demand is
very bursty and that we should not have
this kind of fixed block of resources
you know business hours New York or you
know 24/7 or something like that now
what's more annoying about this is the
fact that you know things like what's
your average cluster size doesn't really
make sense here right I can give you you
know global max over the last six months
you know some kind of local max you know
inter week or something like that but
you know average utilization or average
size don't really make much sense and
beyond the technicality that you know I
cannot give a you know straight number
this is important because you know all
these resources talk back to services
into Sigma and people have to do
capacity planning they need to know if
you know they are going to have if their
service is gonna have you know ten
replicas or twenty replicas and it
creates these frictions right because on
the cloud we're doing these things where
we want to scale up as much as possible
but internally people have limited
resources and they need to you know be
aware of these things so let's talk
about allocation so you know if we recap
we've talked about LSD city we've talked
about how we can you know scale up and
down and you know give these resources
to our users but we also need to do the
to do it in a cost-effective way
an allocation is just one metric for
this usually it hovers between 90 to 95
percent and we can achieve this with
launching and and Cooke
but there are these deeps right every
once in a while there are dips and you
might be thinking you know what's the
deal with that like this guys wrote an
auto scaler and they wrote a scheduler
and they still have like this pretty bad
in efficiencies but they are explainable
and it's really because the the one
thing that we try to optimize for is to
never have a backlog we don't want to be
we move to the cloud and we don't want
to be in a situation where someone has
to wait for resources so grant that we
have you know some kind of restrictions
in in how fast we scale up but we try to
push that boundary you know as far as
possible you know to kind of provide a
good user experience
so let me give you an example of kind of
how you can end up in this situation
suppose at t0 nothing is happening you
know a couple of jobs running on on a
single VM we're at a hundred percent
allocation say at t1 a user comes and
they want to run a couple of workloads
or a couple of jobs now we have a
backlog and this is exactly the
situation that we want to avoid so
koukin launches start doing their thing
they create some VMs they bootstrap you
know they register tomatoes and cook
schedules at and and now the user is
fully running we drop to 90 percent
allocation you know for whatever reason
there was a little inefficiency not such
a big deal but this is when it gets
interesting let's say half a day goes by
and now we're at t 50 most of the jobs
finished but there is still one job in
every single VM and obviously we cannot
terminate this VM because we don't want
to waste this you know progress that
we've made so we keep them alive and
this is when when you see the dips and
this is when allocation drops to 25
percent but there is like a twist to
kind of this example let's say really
most of the jobs finish we terminate the
VMS or were fully idle but there is
still one vm with you know one job
running and we're still at 25 percent
allocation all right so what actually
happened here what we found out over
time is that just looking at this
percentage at face value doesn't really
make much sense and it doesn't give us
the full picture right it's not the same
thing saying we wasted 75% of a hundred
thousand cores cluster then saying
wasted 75 percent of a 500 cost course
cluster right and we rather look at the
you know CPU hour a memory hour and you
know kind of rate that we paid for but
we didn't actually use rather than just
looking at this number and the other
thing but more importantly I think is
you know the fact that you know you have
to keep in mind that we we want to avoid
having a back look at any time we don't
want people just waiting for resources
so you know this allocation thing is the
second kind of priority you know we we
optimized for it but we don't put that
you know we don't try to look good on
kind of on paper over users having a
good eye
experience and this is just one of the
many challenges that we have kind of on
a daily basis and you know that we have
to deal with in this elastic environment
but there's many many more the craze is
going to talk about hello again so we'll
have a few minutes left we know that we
are the last thing standing between you
and lunch so we'll try to get through
these fairly straightforward so we
talked about a lot of the interesting
things and the problems we've solved but
our big challenges so far and what we
have left us all a lot of it does stem
from being hyper cloud and that we're
using dynamic computing Google but all
of our data stores are still on prem
somewhere there's still a sequel server
is still an HDFS cluster and getting all
that data from our data center into
Google to do any computation is a
challenge and we're still we're still
working through the right way to solve
that one especially back pressure as
well so the ability to spin up a 5x data
center is great for our users they love
that that ability our network team our
infrastructure teams they don't love us
and we do that they tend to get very
upset when we DDoS their their services
because of our users so solving those
types of things solving QoS network
network fair share is something that we
haven't even looked at yet so there are
some of the things to really solve and
figure out as Michael mentioned
checkpoint and restore so we talked
about 15 years of history of two sigma
of how we've done research some of the
stuff that was built 10 12 years ago
we're still running and it doesn't
necessarily support checkpointing it
doesn't support restoring so in those
types of use cases it's you know there's
stuff we can do from the engineering
side but it's also stuff we go talk to
our users to figure out can their system
handle it can they go rewrite now to
feature to checkpoint to somewhere and
then figure out how to make their life
more dynamic so some of the takeaways to
get through those the we are able to do
a lot of things now that we couldn't do
before like this has the ability to spin
up yeah data centers with just by an API
call the optionality of it you know
what's the the ability for me to land a
TPU in a data center is none that's not
possible but with Google I can just make
it an API call I'll add a TPU here at 50
GPUs over here is something that our
modelers are really
looking for in it opens up a ton of
research possibilities for them our
investments in things like cook and our
autoscaler have really paid off and open
a bunch of value but then the takeaways
also hybrid cloud introduces a lot of
frictions which a lot of people have
talked about trying to operate both
environments
there's many unsolved problems and then
improving scheduling is and never-ending
quests a lot of the optionality custom
esta sites for example isn't something
that we had two years ago so the idea to
go through and say oh I want you know X
number of CPU X number of RAM is a
really interesting feature but every
time these come out is another
optimization that we can make in our
environment the obligatory we are hiring
across the platform engineering teams or
cloud security teams and even some of
our our data teams that the teams that
are actually using with that are using
some of these services really hard core
are also hiring we have lots of opening
we actually have the slide earlier there
about nine talks by two sigma this week
feel free to check out some of the other
ones some of them are more focused some
of them are more security focus some of
them are more data focus so we recommend
going to see some of those and then last
always thank you I think we have about
five minutes left for Q&A
[Music]